[Music]
i've got just a few days left to crack
vietnamese cooking
this country has nearly 3 000 kilometres
of coastline
so i'm heading to the pretty fishing
village of fantiert to see what they do
with seafood
this morning i'm on my way to meet a
bunch of local fishermen who fish on a
nightly basis for the most amazing squid
off this phenomenal coastline
i'm hooking up with duk chan a chef who
works wonders with seafood
how are you very well good to see you
like everyone else here duke likes his
food as fresh as possible and he's
offered to take me fishing
they're not really boats though are they
oh yeah bathtubs right oh this bad
there's tubs in but there's basketballs
you're missing a few more words in there
that goes out in there it has to be a
basket case what are they these are uh
to go fishing to bring in squids shrimps
yeah and the engine where does the
engine go ah here's the engine
[Laughter]
i can't believe i'm doing this
on there in the middle
these bamboo boats have been used by
squid fishermen for generations and
before i go out fishing i've got to
learn how it's done back and forth back
and forth powder push to go forward
basically
it looks effortless it looks like it
doesn't he's not doing any clothes with
the water no get your stand get your
kung fu stand standing
wow
jesus oh god i feel so stupid
this
is probably the most difficult run i've
ever done
40 minutes later they seem to think i'm
getting the hang of it no i'm not
convinced
[Music]
mr basket case he wants to race can i
just at least have a five meter head
start
okay you basket cases
basket fisherman on your mart
get set go
[Applause]
it's back to beginner's class for me i'm
stuck in reverse
guys this way
this way
wrong way
what the [ __ ]
come on
excuse me hello come and lift
boat's full of water
that was hard
bloody hard i'm excited about catching
squid
but not in a [ __ ] wicker basket no
the best time to catch squid is at night
and as the day ends the fleet get down
to business
this is incredible
they're now getting their
tilley lamps set up and the idea is to
light the mantle get it nice and bright
turn it around and that will start to
attract the squid that's my boat
and that one there
it's duck show me your squid in 10
minutes
okay
yeah
fatty hell
[Music]
duck
yes what do they do out here all night
rice wines
freshly cooked squid right on top of
here man they cook the squid on top of
the yeah they have a party themselves
incredible
don't their wives miss them
the wife missed the squid more than they
were the husband haven't jesus
come on baby where are these squids
after two hours i haven't got a bite
any pooling any squid
nothing
but the pros have landed some beauties
look at that that's what we came for
those babies there
beautiful beautiful doesn't get any
better than that does it
i've never seen squid that fresh look at
them
and now they are doomed for the walk
i'm going to clean it up now yeah we're
going to now seafood supreme duke is
going to show me a delicious vietnamese
favorite stuff squid yeah so we
basically we're going to use
all of it this is the little beak beaks
right here vietnamese loves it it's a
tooth it's a tooth outside of it it's
like uh the membrane that to hold the
tooth together so it's crunchy oh nice
the vietnamese love taxis textiles in
english it's like eating a gum there we
go yeah nice so from snake bones to gums
yeah
oh holy moly
squid shooting man according to european
they usually eat that ink you know maybe
a black
spaghetti or something like that do you
use it here no not yet wow that's
fantastic news don't give them my idea
that's the first time in vietnam okay i
found something you don't eat
squid ink
i found something the brits eat that the
vietnamese don't but for me this complex
squid dish beats that deep-fried version
any day
50 50 here tentacles chopped up and 50
percent of the poor right a little bit
of garlic yeah and a little bit of
ginger as well
we're gonna stop this squid and a little
bit of fish sauce i'm amazed to put fish
sauce in there well i mean if you don't
put cooked fish sauce in vietnam then
you use some sort of like foreigners
here then enjoy drop it in there please
and now the base of the sauce is ginger
garlic and onion ginger garlic onion
yeah
nice they look fantastic
nice tattoo gordon
i've dressed a few squids in my time all
right
haven't [ __ ] caught many
i've dressed a few would you try hard
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i can't wait to dig in and to see if the
sea dogs are as impressed with duke's
dish as i am
i've got the biggest piece of squid in
for you yeah here we are the honor my
man right there
how's the squidward
it's perfect thank you for being so
brilliant and so patient
amazing uh come take away
it's a pleasure to see you here and
you're not drunk not going home tonight
is that the same stuff from these
lanterns
no
here we go
[Music]
mr tip
congratulations honestly balls of steel
it's been an amazing day
getting out to sea and cooking the catch
is as simple as it gets and i've loved
getting back to basics
i didn't grow up with much money around
the table yet in a very humble way but
here even if you haven't got much money
you eat in an amazing way a very fresh
way they don't realize to what a great
standard they eat at so cheaply
i've just arrived in ho chi minh it's
the foodie capital of the south and i'm
here to get my induction to this
country's incredible food
went into the
city yes yes i've never been to vietnam
before and i can't wait to get started
for me the idea of escape is to is to go
to a country where you're not noticed
bed down more importantly
turn the phone off and just
just disappear
i mean really disappear
just me and food that's it
it's 10 in the morning and already it's
a boiling 35 degrees
[Music]
i
[ __ ]
the air conditioner's not working then
[Music]
this country is famed for exotic
delicacies and fantastically fresh
ingredients
and i've heard the vietnamese are a
nation of fearless foodies
rumored to
waste nothing and eat everything
everyone says in france it's the nose to
tail
over here
completely different level if it moves
they eat it that's new territory for me
here we go
[Music]
my first stop is the mother of all fresh
food markets ben tang
this is vietnam's answer to our
supermarkets but here the food is as
fresh as it gets
wow look at this place
[Music]
it's amazing
where's the fish section
fish fish
here
it's the liveliest market i've been to
many ingredients still have a pulse
unbelievable everything's out open
fresh she's taking the heads of the
shrimp there everything's just so
vibrant alive
fresh and kicking
incredible
[Music]
freshness is king in vietnam and i'm
here to meet a woman whose reputation
relies on it
mrs v
how are you
nice to see you guys yes
you're shopping yes what an amazing
place hello hello how are you
v ching owns four of the country's
hottest restaurants she creates a new
menu every day using the market for
inspiration
so this is your local market yeah and
how many times a day you come here twice
the average person in britain goes
shopping once a week we have to shop
every day why every day
because they're a fresh ingredient you
can see everything's still alive yeah
yep
bloody hell and this is normal to have
the frogs out here like that with a
backpack so if you wanted to get one
they would cut it off for you so they
just oh
yes
this is how we bought it you just bought
them like the whole thing you're not
going to waste anything and what are
they down there catfish
but you got to buy when everything's
still like whoa that's strong would you
eat them that small the catfish being
that tiny now you eat the whole thing
the whole thing the whole thing you're
not going to waste anything oh we have
no dairy so the bone is so important to
get some calcium so no dairy and that's
why you overthink the bone the food
you're gonna eat everything you're
actually shopping fresher than a lot of
russians do back up
all this leaping and wriggling might
look the stuff of nightmares but
ingredients this fresh are a chef's
dream
right what are we gonna cook
these hijacked a stall to show me how to
turn these clams you just bought into a
stunning dish you can tell how fresh
they are because they're just so firm
and it's like trying to get into the
pentagon you can't even pierce it open
it's incredible the more fresh the more
harder oh my god come on
yeah then you put about quarter cup of
shallot oil okay spring onions
we mix about a teaspoon of nutmeg into
it it's official
yeah
so fish sauce
crucial to the ingredient
so we need some dressing onto each clam
so how do they take it i always say
that's about um three minutes again it's
all charcoal isn't it because you don't
have oven so everything's just sort of
open flamed mmm that's incredible that
look how quick that cooks you know where
the cup oh get it
love it
can't turn the gas down
done
i love these no fuss approach in minutes
she's turned raw ingredients into the
ultimate fast food
they smell fantastic
right i'm dying to eat one of them yeah
i'm gonna pour that juice on there now
then yeah you pour the sauce on top
nice delicious who needs a seafood bar
we've got a market like this oh my god
and i'm only here for a week so
what a great start thank you you're
welcome but i think one week is not
enough you should spend longer time so
you don't think i can learn enough in
one week i think it's too short too
short i'll come back at the end of the
week and prove to you okay all right
i'll wait for that time thank you they
were delicious good to see you love the
hat by the way
thank you thanks darling
via's up the ante and now i have a lot
to prove
he has to be right to doubt me because
it's an insult to her culture to come
here
and tell her be up to her speed after 31
years cooking that style of food within
seven days
you